this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 44 Echo Charles sitting here with
me I've been thinking a lot about this
term I heard
a little while ago
but it seems to just be more and more
important and more impactful all the
time the the term is social Contagion
and it you know in a nutshell it's like
a fad right it's like a fad of something
but you know when you think of fad you
think of hula hoops right or Rubik's
Cubes what you don't think of is
something like suicide or
cutting yourself which is a thing that
happens with people they they get into
self-harm so
I I was just reading a little bit about
it some excerpts here from uh
psychologytoday.com
starts off with this little example in
1774 Johann Wolfgang von Gault
published a book called The Sorrows of
young Werther in the novel The main
character were there shoots himself with
a pistol after he's rejected by the
woman he loves
shortly after the book's publication
there were reports of young men dressing
in yellow pants and Blue Jackets like
Werther and shooting themselves in Acts
of hopelessness this resulted in the
book being banned in several places
the phenomenon of CopyCat suicides which
has been verified numerous times by
research in recent decades has become
known as The Werther effect alright we
all I also heard Jordan Peterson I think
he talked about on when he was on our
podcast
if you have they they have like
experiments or they have data that when
they put Suicide Prevention signs up in
a town or in a city
you know call 1-800 if you're feeling
depressed to help you get over Suicidal
Thoughts suicide increases
because that that idea is getting in
people's head
um I guess that's not quite a social
contagion it's to me that's the idea of
this idea getting into your head
being placed there
the idea gets placed there and if the
idea wouldn't have been placed there
it's like a little seed that gets
planted and then it grows
and the but what I think part of the
social contagion aspect is that right
now there's so many ways that a seed can
get planted in your head
right primarily
social media I mean you can stare at
this freaking little screen all day and
have people pump ideas into your head
uh going back to this article social
contagion is more a general phenomenon
extending far beyond suicide it is the
spread of ideas attitudes or patterns or
behavior patterns in a group through
imitation and Conformity among other
factors
the American Psychological association's
definition of social contagion lists a
few of the of those processes so you got
the first one is imitation copying the
behavior of another personal group
intentionally or unintentionally that's
interesting right it's not even
intentional you see what everyone's
doing you kind of go along with it in
some situations there can be also be an
element of mimicry in which people
without conscious awareness or intent
automatically copy other people's
physical movements
that's that happens and you know you
hear um like interrogators
they'll
they'll mimic people's movements to kind
of build some
what's the word rapport rapport with
them yeah you know you put your hand on
your head I put my hand on your head you
kind of like show you that I'm alone
with you yeah
next one Conformity and the pressure to
conform Conformity is the adjustment of
one's opinions judgments or actions so
that they become more consistent with
the group boom we all know about that
yeah
but are you aware of it
I think that's like the the overall
underlying thread of my thought this is
are you aware of this stuff are you
aware that's happening are you aware
that you're imitating people are you
aware that they're conforming to their
ideas are you aware of it are you
thinking through things and actually
questioning what you're doing or you're
just going along with it because you're
unaware of the fact that it's happening
yeah
next one University
universitality universality sorry
universality which refers to the
tendency to assumes to assume that one's
attitudes or behaviors are common to
everyone in the group and are
permissible because everyone's doing it
that's what everybody's doing it
as in the case of rule breaking by a
crowd or mob
this has a disinhibiting effect as well
as reinforcing effect setting up a
circle reaction so you do it I do it you
see that I did it you do it more I do it
more we just go in this this circular
reaction
and Anatomy
impulsivity and feelings of
invincibility also play important rules
in mob situations so that's you know
mobs is an example of this of this
social Contagion
and so if you're in a mob if you're in a
group and you start doing things
question what you're doing that's my
underlying thread of this whole thing
that's what I've been asking myself
it goes on to this other section some
some other factors mediating social
contagion might include the need for
approval or affiliation sharing the
others goals or inferring or
understanding their intentions and
motivations being quote inspired
and impressed by the other and in some
cases trying to gain recognition or even
notoriety by surpassing the quote
accomplishment of the other
as in the case of anti-social
Psychopathic acts such as mass shootings
you know you see that with like kids
drinking alcohol yeah adults too but I
have sorry adults drinking alcohol yeah
just like oh I'm gonna drink more than
you yeah
I played that game before
it's a dumb game to play it's social
contagion I should have been saying
myself why are you doing this right now
yeah what are you doing what are you
trying to what are you trying to prove
something too
we trying to prove there buddy
um this is an interesting one emotional
contagion God we're seeing this all the
time right the rapid spread of an
emotion from one or a few individuals to
others as in a political Rally or a
sports Stadium packed with fans or even
just a room full of fronts
so your emotions are contagious
which you know from a leadership
perspective we say that all the time hey
if you start to panic everyone's gonna
start to panic if you remain calm
everyone starts to remain calm
but man if you can if you allow yourself
to get caught up in this stuff without
being aware of it to me that's a problem
group think
the next one group think as may occur
for example in political organizations
or in corporations in which cohesiveness
or the desire for cohesiveness within a
group produces a tendency among its
members to agree at all costs
which leads the group to minimize
conflict and reach consensus without
critical evaluation without critical
evaluation
sounds good to me that's what we're
doing as you know you you always make
that comment that's what we're doing
sure you know that's what we're doing
hey if that's what we're doing yeah
you're you're on board I'm down for the
cause you know would you do that
remember when you did your parents ever
say to you if your friends wrote off a
cliff would you follow them
that is though really and it makes you
perspective a little bit really when
because when your parents say that to
you it's like they're putting it into
perspective that you're just freaking
following the group and not critically
thinking about your parents did say that
to you yes sir okay we have plenty of
times and I and I was just like whatever
I didn't think too much about until
later when I was an adult I think my
parents were mostly telling me like hey
you should do what other people are
doing freaking settle down
like can't you just act like everybody
else why do you gotta be over here you
know they wanted me to be more
conforming and more uh more group think
they're telling you hey jump off a
bridge do something normal
like I you know I was like a straight
edge kid yes sir I was that and that was
not normal you know the normal kids were
out you know smoking some weeds
smoking cigarette smoking cloves
remember cloves they might not have made
it to your AO closed up well it was like
a thing not I mean these two brothers in
the 80s you know what I'm smoking cloves
so when you were straight edge how old
were you about
uh you know and here's the thing we've
kind of gone through this before so
straight edge is like a whole like
legitimate movement and there's factions
in it and all this kind of stuff but
when you got turned on to the philosophy
yeah yeah I mean I was like between the
eight this is for me between the ages of
like probably 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
I'm in I'm in the Navy so when when were
people like smoking cigarettes or
smoking weed or whatever
let's say 12 13 14 15 16. wow that's
crazy right man uh well I don't know
they oh I've heard that before too but I
don't I don't know maybe I was in a
bubble or what but there would be people
smoking who were like 13 14 15 years old
and that was just crazy
for everyone yeah they're like true
that's crazy smoking weed no kids that I
knew of really until like maybe senior
year type situation yeah that I saw
anyway I tell you what nowadays it's
crazy yeah like kids are into all that
kind of crap at a young young age but
I was in that mode
and most very few people other people
you know most of the kids most of the
kids that were like my age and they were
you know
smoking some weed drinking some booze
you know getting after it in that room
uh continue on here members of a group
can can often feel peer pressure to go
along with the crowd for fear of rocking
the boat or out of concern for their
teammates perceptions of them cool peer
pressure we get that
presence of a highly influential
domineering authoritative role model
so that's when people are just going
along because you know like whatever the
big the big leaders doing it um
um the human propensity to be strongly
swayed by compelling narratives oh good
story guys that person's got a good
story that's why you see advertisers use
that kind of stuff stories oh yeah yeah
stories to make you think a certain way
yeah they do a good job sometimes too
yeah I think something sometimes
sometimes there's commercials that you
know that they did a good job on that
one but that's what I think I always
think I don't think wow I want to buy
that product I said man that Advertiser
did a good job on that one because I'm
questioning these bastards yeah yeah
because I'm probably the worst person to
advertise too yeah I'm such a jerk when
it comes to people trying to get me to
do
isn't that kind doesn't that kind of and
maybe something just think about isn't
that kind of like an opening to
advertise to you even more effectively
though because you're kind of rigid in
that way I mean we can argue about the
semantics of it like rigidity but if
you're like the worst guy to advertise
to all you got to do is basically find
the correct way to advertise you and it
might be super highly influential you
know I'm if someone pulls that off it'll
be I'll probably be devastated you know
I'll probably be buying whatever uh you
know Flowbee hair cutting vacuum thing
for your head well I guess it depends on
what you mean by everything what is that
I don't even know the difference between
advertising and marketing uh maybe
marketing there might be some technical
things yeah yeah but let's say a
marketing campaign to get Jocko to not
do something to get me to not do
something yeah that's like not a typical
thing right usually a commercial is
gonna want you to do something usually
unless you have these like causes or
whatever but I think someone could get
you they'd be like all they got to do is
launch this campaign oh they could use
reverse psychology exactly right yeah
yeah exactly that's what I think so I
gotta be aware of reverse psychology
yeah that someone's gonna go do not
yeah try this you will not like this
this drink yeah and then show a bunch of
stories that you like basically disagree
with or show a bunch of people that
you're like can't relate to or something
you're like oh I'm not like them so I'm
gonna can't relate yeah which is very
easy to do but uh and This falls into
suggestibility the social social
contagion is accelerated by a high
degree of suggestibility suggestibility
is a high pot highly potent
underestimated force with manifestations
extending far beyond social contagion
what is suggestibility suggestibility is
the quality of being inclined to accept
and act on the suggestions of others or
being easily influenced by other
people's opinions it also usually
applies
implies a state of uncritical compliance
with an influence this is so
I think to what you were trying to say
about me a second ago
this is where
I think I I have a like a tendency just
to be like I'm not listening to this
person that's been trying to make me do
something yeah I have a real
that'll piss me off now look I'm not out
of control with it I'm not like yeah but
I definitely am aware that my first
reaction is going to be a pushback I
don't show that but that's my internal
mental reaction is a little pushback
I have to kind of keep it in check so I
can actually listen to what people have
to say but it's it's a it's a little bit
of a you know internal
discussion in my head
these manifestations of social contagion
and suggestibility are wide-ranging here
are a few examples in the mental health
field in which a problem probably has
been at least Amplified by social
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
immobilized